in dell'est e pisa pezzo di carne non
identificato flip a qualche chiazza riti
zio cane si capelli arco di ars
tartaglia vince verso di stark si no
così da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo no io sono fra vj sono qui oggi
che i capelli a darvi il benvenuto per
questo video incredibile di più e amica
quant'è bella litro fatta perfetta
all'atto box cus rock swing
l'ex coach del rock swing ragazzi allora
il primo livello dio nessuno te l'ha mai
detto che devi stare calmo ma calmo
proprio dramma la botta in faccia c'è
sono già palla zio michè ho fatto più
più rock swing che tu giorni sulla terra
non so se si è capito quello che
intendeva un mamma bene che brutto esto
es toro psichica mi sembra bambini zio
io voglio cose impossibili cioè tu stai
parlando porre dei rokes in quanto et
ratio livello o mio dio se non mi fa
incazzare nel senso non mi fa spaventare
non sono morto c'è la scritta ferre non
ho afferrato sono un [ __ ] bene e
avevo appena detto che questo non
livello per bambini e appunto e per
bambini però non riesco a fare neanche
questo ci devono essere dei problemi di
fondo oddio passion nelle rotelle di
liquirizia sotto no macché buona canzone
venuta voglia di liquirizia graham g g
moneygram finirà prima o poi sto river
non è non finisce mai ragazzi ex trouble
phone
ora devo morire me lo sento che sta
durando troppo sto livello capace che
arrivò all'ultima palla e crepe effetto
mi sono un po cagato prof va bene
abbiamo suo ragionamento a nader
dimension spesso continua fermi un
attimo questo dio e la quale altra volta
dove si compra la lamborghini afferma la
posso prendere non la posso prendere in
compenso posso portarmi dietro questa
deliziosa bottiglietta di ketchup che ho
perso è il nice to meet you and
professional a number
comunque se i nonno ciak con un camice
mi fa veramente schifo è perfetto oddio
la tavola periodica degli elementi
charter names breaking bad non faccio la
metanfetamina ragazzi alla fine non sa
che si scopre che uolter white con la
barba allora xp y uguale tre non sono
capace
che cazzo in stargate vado in un'altra
dimensione che bello ci sono i pop corn
dall'altra parte se non ci vado
non so che cosa sia ma sicuramente non è
il rumore di un popcorn
io l'avevo già fatto sto livello me lo
ricordo casa prema per rendervene conto
ci ho messo anche un po e c'è tipo
questa l'alzheimer che fa effetto
regalavo già fatto suo livello è morto
qui adesso non ci sono morto perché sono
diventato più forte
sei caduto nel continuum spazio
temporale e come tua sorella zio alla
fine water botto il flip facciamo questo
che in questo sicuramente non l'ho fatto
ok magari se cade in piedi mi fa un
favore no in piedi dall altra parte zio
in piedi dall altra no in piedi dall
altra parte non capisci un cazzo
evidentemente apre ragazzi un livello di
rape bellissimo la prossima lo fanno di
barbabietole per adesso
[Musica]
bene world troy impossibile perché tu
pensi che io riesca non va bene
ecco la vj ragazzi 1 youtuber vero 80
per cento in prossimo al baio beaches
questo mi manca una domanda ma secondo
voi se colpisco l'arpione che ha
attraversato il muro mi uccide mi
uccidono psicosi perché non li ucci e
stavo scherzando
beh tua madre [ __ ] tra mai detto bene
te lo dico io fermi scommessa quanto
scommettete che riesco a farlo senza
morire un'altra volta stavolta ci riesco
sicuro perché ho capito il metodo non
questo ok ride sì era proprio questo che
un giuro che volevo fare proprio così ho
fatto
a partire da adesso ragazzi proviamo a
mettere sullo sfondo di e pv su un altro
video mio di happy voi scrivete un
bordello bene sto capendo tutto
fantastico e più inception ragazzi
perfetto
non sto capendo un casto ragazzi
bene voi non avete capito ma ho vinto
cioè non avete capito cosa è successo ma
va bene così try to stop prova a
fermarti dio mio questi sono imposti e
va beh non mi serve
ho vinto però non so perché la mia testa
è rimasta appesa a testa in giù va bene
secondo me ragazzi se ci prova un paio
di eva beh bene non sono riuscito a
fermarmi credo dicevo se ci riprova un
paio di volte un paio per 33 frena era
un buona la prima ragazzi rotto il
feeling proprio cosa prosciutto porca
eva c'ero perché proprio io secondo me
ci riprovo un po di volte se lo faccio a
rimbalzare sul cerchio rosso riesco in
teoria credo è porca [ __ ] come lo mette
carcuro ragazzi miei
è così che si conquista la patata non
smetterò mai di dirlo mai perché voi
dovete capire come conquistare del team
perché se no che cosa ci sta a fare io
quasi non mi insegnò come conquistare la
[ __ ] così test your life 2 o quella che
ti fanno testare la fortuna amica quanto
sono contento di vedere quanto sfigato a
merda barun avevo dubbi è volevi
bastardo secondo riesco a dare niente
non ci riesce per un attimo sono
diventato il tipo brutto di the forest
se riuscissi a buttarmi io
va bene va bene non importa aspect cross
only maglia con chi stai parlando di
roma si sta rendendo conto bene forse ci
hai ragione tutta la carne macinata
innanzitutto perché perfetto
chi è che brutto salto fatto regali
[Musica]
fighter 99,99 per cento ma io non riesco
a farli poco fight mica go in mano ogni
volta madonna che scusa li stavo tirando
col poco mi acqua eva pezzi io non so
che cazzo è stata 9 lo champagne mettono
ansia i livelli non so perché fai tu chi
yourself prova ad ucciderti che cazzo ci
vuole scusa ma effettivamente non è così
facile come penso volevi provarono farvi
scassa lelli kotra mi sono scassato da
solo non è così difficile anzi ho creato
anche un frullatore tra l'altro perfetto
non provate a sfidarmi sul prova ad
ucciderti che sono un campione in quel
che gli emo possono accompagnare solo
seal the diamond oddio anche qua lo
stile minchia che palle sapete qual è il
problema io mi faccio a tirare dal nome
e dico mica che figo e stile la chiamo
ancora dovete andare a ruba reja invece
noi questa merda di coso di arpioni di
merda che non riesco a farlo manco per
sbaglio porca vacca live che cazzo ci fa
un arpione li vedi capirmi zio perché
mica non c'ho voglia di farlo 300 volte
bene basta la prossima volta non mi
faccio più infinocchiare da si livelli
che non è possibile ram slash corre ai
sbagliato dice corri non corre veloce a
zio veloci a corre veloce a corre borg
android corre
siamo ritornati borga du roi a torre ma
dal padre ora che mi chieda la vita che
non faccio i livelli miei prova a fare
prima questo e per provare livelli mi sa
che da un secolo che adesso ci penso
se questa merda cos'è sta roba addio
clicca in us le emozioni che mi
trasmette questo livello non lo
trasmette nessuno neanche pupo quando
canta dove ragazzi facciamo un paio di
miei livelli come ho detto prima perché
da una vita che non li faccio mica se
devo proprio peggio contro donald donald
chi donald trump spiega farmi capire che
c'è chiedo ma che cazzo riti origini
dello strano speriamo che non sia strano
miccoli piazza affari è il mio primo
livello spero ti piace va bene favino
andare quindi non ci vado
una volta ci andavo adesso no bravo
adesso salta nel vuoto mi hai detto di
saltare nel vuoto sono saltato nel vuoto
qual è il problema fa vj 200 per cento
impossible poi faccio questa qua frigid
imploro da ciocco succo che è un
nickname che zio veramente complimenti
ci avvolge queste vedere licata te ti
prego salutami no come ti chiami yo yo
yo yo game ciao giorgio gamer che bel
nome che hai con questo la [ __ ] arriva
ancora di più per josé completerei
questo livello subito cazzo fare felice
ma non è non regge sto palo non è
stabile non è stabile
ce ne sono le spine sul traguardo me
faccio o butto sul tronco direttamente
un ragazzo finisca perché sm miyake
salto da uil
sono vivo sono morto porca [ __ ] non
ci fosse stata quella freccia maledetta
l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho fatta ciao
fatta bene va bene così grazie giorgio
gamer questo bellissimo livello va
vicinissimo facciamo questo perché di
sguardo traumi e non so da quanto dammi
la birra donna clicca stai guardando la
parte sbagliata cosa chicca che cazzo
picco ok perché non c'è chi ci ha due
cervelli già pensavo non avesse neanche
uno dei regali o che valerio è va beh
chi devo colpire per vincere non
capitolo portiere babbo natale dovrei sa
o squartato una bambina mamma perché
lasciamo per vara va bene così per oggi
va bene d'accordo ragazzi ai miei
capelli
diciamo vi diciamo ciao novi vi diciamo
che effettivamente i miei livelli
aggiungono sempre un tocco di classe a
quello che è più perché i miei sono
intelligenti gli altri berlino come
avete potuto vedere ragazzini spero che
vi sia piaciuto con cui bisogna cose
insieme fusione nel momento è un mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e
crotone descrizione si iscrive temi ci
mettiamo un prossimo vita e ragazzi